[Music]
on this wednesday night fighting the
fourth wave
hospitals in several provinces
struggling to cope with climbing covid
cases our
ability to provide comprehensive care
has collapsed the warnings and regrets
from alberta's top doctor canadians cost
of living climbs to an 18-year high from
gas to groceries how big will those
bills become
the thirst for change on a manitoba
first nation clean drinking water for
the first time in decades
and the peculiar path from secret
service to public life i was in the
shadows for so many years the former
officer with ces now vying to be an mp
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight jeff semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us covet 19 cases are climbing across
the country and premiers are now
grappling with how to control the latest
wave without rolling back reopening
plans new brunswick just had its highest
single day jump of the pandemic with 63
new cases saskatchewan has 475 new cases
today its second highest number after
yesterday's record tally nearly 20
percent of those new cases are in
children under 12 too young to be
vaccinated saskatchewan and alberta now
have among the highest covid19 case
rates in the country and the lowest
vaccination rates as heather urix west
explains doctors warn health systems are
again on the brink of collapse
bryn marx is determined to stay positive
the edmonton teenager has an incurable
lung disease and was supposed to have
surgery next week to improve her quality
of life but we got the call yesterday
that
it has been canceled pretty much
indefinitely as alberta struggles to
care for what is now a record number of
covet patients in the icu thousands of
elective surgeries have been canceled
across the province our ability to
provide comprehensive
care has collapsed and i know that in
the last couple of weeks
there were 15 or 20
big cancer cases that had to be
postponed
those patients could be affected by this
it could it could end up shortening
their lives in neighboring saskatchewan
surgeries are being canceled too a
consequence of a summer free of
restrictions both provinces lifted all
measures back in july in a candid web
conference with family doctors tuesday
alberta's chief medical health officer
admitted that was a mistake i think if
we look at the experiences of all of the
different provinces across the country
those that have kept in
some base level
restrictions to manage the interactions
and close contacts are the ones that are
not seeing the significant impact a
lesson perhaps for the rest of the
country but for alberta and saskatchewan
the time to act is now you don't just
magically put this genie back in the
bottle
you have to act quickly in order to
reduce that exponential spread
saskatchewan has yet to impose even a
mandatory mask mandate and vaccine
passports aren't in use in either
province though alberta's government is
expected to announce new measures later
today what we've been doing is not
working everybody can see that lots of
examples of increasing suffering
increasing sub-optimal outcomes and for
sure increasing deaths an insufficient
response to the fourth wave creating a
crisis now affecting thousands beyond
those sick with coveted 19. i don't
focus on me but
it is important for other kiddos to get
that treatment
and be safe heather urex west global
news calgary
with just days to go in the federal
election campaign the race appears to be
tightening ips's polling done for global
news shows the liberals and tories are
in a dead heat each with about 32
percent support aaron o'toole is
promising a more progressive
conservative party but as michael
couture explains some party members are
muddying that message
we're not your dad's conservative party
anymore in the waning days of this
campaign aaron o'toole is trying to
rebrand his team but to help the party
brought out a grandfather of modern
conservatism brian mulroney he will
bring honor
and accomplishment
to the position of prime minister of
canada the endorsement of the former
progressive conservative prime minister
comes as the party is trying to move
past controversies involving climate
change and vaccination cheryl gallant
was forced to take down videos denying
climate science and tuesday conservative
ted falk was forced to apologize for
spreading misinformation about vaccines
claiming you were 13 times more likely
to die from the delta variant if you
were double vaccinated than if you were
unvaccinated the candidate in question
apologized and clarified the record so
about that rebranding
i am a new leader with a new style i've
said that many times here in quebec a
resurgence of the bloc quebecois could
stunt any gains the conservatives were
hoping to make
senior party sources tell global news
they feel more seats for the block mean
fewer for the liberals possibly paving
the way for a conservative government
jeff
thanks mike
and that tightening race could also
change how canadians vote instead of
choosing the candidate they support
people may choose to vote strategically
but as robin gill explains the ndp
leader hopes that people will vote based
on their values
[Music]
jug meet singh is on your side that's
what the new democrats want voters to
believe but two ndp candidates have left
his side just ahead of election day
these candidates made a decision to
leave i think that was the right
decision toronto sydney coles tweeted
unsubstantiated claims that israel had
taken away supplies of the coven 19
vaccine then there's nova scotia's dan
osborne back in 2019 he apparently
tweeted at oprah winfrey asking was
auschwitz a real place
the party says both agreed to learn more
about anti-semitism but singh didn't
demand they quit now he's left to
apologize for them anti-semitism is real
we're seeing a scary rise
but this doesn't appear to be hurting
the new democrats according to party
strategists they're holding steady with
21 percent support from those polled it
feels like the ndp vote is more solid
and it's been in the in the past when it
comes to the strategic rolling play of
the liberals
the likability factor jackman sing is
the most popular leader out there right
now
the ndp leader is resonating the most in
british columbia third place in ontario
and essentially in last place in quebec
its greatest threat is a familiar one
bleeding progressive votes to the
liberals who stand a better chance of
forming government for now singh is
still playing offense there is a cost to
voting for mr trudeau
the ndp has the opportunity here to hold
the balance of power in this tight race
pollsters say don't discount those
advanced votes because they account for
25 percent of the ballot count there's
one other factor more mail-in ballots
this time around jeff
thanks robin
this campaign has turned particularly
ugly at times as abigail beeman reports
candidates of all stripes are facing
verbal and even physical aggression
two people have been charged in one case
assault with a weapon and another
uttering threats after two separate
justin trudeau ontario campaign events
monday sudbury liberal candidate mark
zuray was pinned against a wall in his
campaign office a woman who now faces
charges allegedly hit his hands to stop
him from recording her and later
confronted him at his car banging on the
hood we've always done positive
campaigns
but it's been it's been a challenging
challenging few weeks a growing list of
candidates have experienced hate and
vandalism along the trail it's a small
narrow group of people that are
obviously frustrated about our
government's strong position
in fighting against covet i have felt
anger
and hate
many of my signs have been vandalized my
constituency office storefront has been
vandalized
the police are involved and it's not
just liberals without a mask on they
pushed one of our our volunteers
took a swing at them and then and then
spit in their face was a very serious
incident this conservative candidate in
kitchener says police are investigating
we've seen many trudeau protesters hold
people's party of canada signs in
condemning the trudeau stone thrower
leader maxim bernier says he's not
immune and had an egg thrown at him i
had a brick thrown through my window at
home i was
called all kinds of names i mean that's
fairly standard operating procedure
former deputy prime minister sheila kopp
says what's different now is social
media's power to help mobilize rage i
think the number of incidents and the
boldness of the
people that are tracking the prime
minister is quite scary it's all about
the social media eco ecosystem in
particular i think in the echo chambers
that are built up there that people
you know find themselves you know
inadvertently being pulled into
some of these
these venues no one has a catch-all
answer about where all this hate is
coming from i asked trudeau whether he's
telling candidates to step up safety or
security considerations he said
absolutely
abigail beeman global news fredericton
global news has learned exclusive new
details involving the military police
investigation into canada's former
defense chief general jonathan vance
will not face any further charges
mercedes stephenson joins us now with
the details mercedes
jeff canada's former top soldier retired
general jonathan vance is above the law
military law that is that's according to
the department of national defense
global news has learned that the
military justice system is unable to
prosecute vance due to his high rank
meaning vance is untouchable by military
courts a senior source told global news
it would not be possible to prosecute
vance or any other chief of the defense
staff in a court martial for a breach of
military law including sexual misconduct
that would also apply to admiral art
mcdonald the chief of the defense staff
who had to step aside amid a probe into
sexual misconduct the military justice
system requires the judge to outrank the
accused and nobody outranks a four-leaf
general or admiral
that means the most powerful officers in
the military cannot be held accountable
by their own justice system an
indictment of the system and a concern
victims and experts have raised
repeatedly that sexual misconduct was
endemic at the senior levels of the
forces in part due to a perception of
invincibility government and military
officials had dismissed the concerns
about the military justice system's
ability to hold senior officers
accountable
vance is still facing a charge of
obstructing justice in criminal court
the result of a police investigation
that alleges he instructed major kelly
brennan to lie about their past
relationship a senior source told global
news a charge in the criminal justice
system was the only option investigators
could pursue
in a recent report retired supreme court
justice morris fish warned that the
military justice system may not be able
to deliver justice when the accused
holds the rank of lieutenant general or
higher the question now is whether the
next government will create an
independent military watchdog that
reports to parliament something both
conservative leader aaron o'toole and
ndp leader jug meat singh committed to
liberal leader justin trudeau would not
commit to that yet when asked today
saying he was waiting on the advice of
experts jeff all right
mercedes-stevenson in ottawa thanks
well get ready to dig deeper coming up
soaring inflation why your grocery bill
is going up
affordability is one of the top issues
for voters and statistics canada
confirms the cost of living is climbing
fast the inflation rate hit 4.1 percent
last month the highest level since back
in 2003
and gaviola has more on what's driving
that inflation increase
you can blame a housing market gone wild
in many parts of the country but the
cost of living is also climbing because
of the pandemic recovery prices at the
pumps are going up as economies around
the world reopen so-called revenge
travel as people shell out for vacations
after being cooped up and the rising
price of almost every type of food
you've probably noticed it on your
grocery bill we've never shut down whole
sections of the economy before and then
reopen them all at the same time as has
been happening so this is a very unusual
situation we recognize that that
families are concerned about
affordability the issue was front and
center today on the campaign trail i
think mr trudeau is going to cost you i
also think mr o'toole is going to cost
you the conservatives blame the liberals
claiming they've let inflation run
rampant and that unprecedented
government spending is worsening the
situation but fighting inflation is the
purview of the central bank and global
forces are behind the inflationary trend
inflation's even higher in the united
states than it is here so i don't know
how they could blame that on mr trudeau
food inflation wasn't the biggest driver
but researchers at dalhousie's agri-food
lab which tracks prices say the official
data doesn't capture the extent of it
we're on track to see the average family
shell out nearly 700 more for groceries
this year the biggest increase yet and
this is happening alongside so-called
shrink flation where packaged amounts of
food gets smaller it's a less obvious
way to make you pay more analysts say
food inflation boils down to
covet-related supply chain issues rising
prices for wheat corn and other staples
which impact all kinds of other foods
labor issues and climate change i
actually think it's a little unfair to
blame the current government for food
inflation you can manage it by trimming
what you spend on food and cutting back
on driving every little bit helps as
economists predict elevated inflation is
here to stay for the rest of the year
and beyond and gaviola global news
toronto
still ahead the long road to clean
drinking water for a first nation
welcome back for the first time in more
than two decades shoal lake 41st nation
has clean running water as marny bunt
explains it marks the end of one of
canada's longest boil water advisories
a new day and a new sense of hope on
show lake 40 first nation nestled on the
manitoba ontario border there is joy and
relief here in marking the end of a 24
year boil water advisory the emotions
running through today is like
it's unbelievable
also
it's about that time the community
opening a new water treatment plant and
finally turning on the taps
clean drinking water for the first time
in decades despite living on the lake
that is the source of winnipeg's water
supply we struggled
for over two years with bottled water
deliveries
and
the reality of the project coming to an
end is
surreal a milestone for a community also
opening a new school this week all made
possible following the opening of
freedom road two years ago a 14
kilometer gravel stretch connecting the
once cut off community to the
trans-canada highway before then travel
in and out came only by barge or ice
road it's heartwarming actually to even
to be
to be a witness here and being a part of
it and this is where i'm from we finally
have that
water where we don't have to boil it
in order to drink it shoal lake is one
of 105 first nations communities the
federal government has pledged to lift
long-term boil water advisories on a
promise that's been a long time coming
and want to acknowledge that this should
never
have happened in the first place
there is no excuse
that the federal government can present
for any first nation
being on a long-term water advisory in a
country such as ours
now schull lake has a new sense of hope
and a new beginning i'm just
speechless
and a clear path to a better future
marnie blunt global news show lake on
the manitoba ontario border
back in 2015 the federal liberals
promised to end all boil water
advisories on first nations by march of
this year many have been lifted but 51
communities still do not have clean
drinking water on monday liberal party
leader justin trudeau was asked about
his party's efforts towards indigenous
reconciliation during an interview with
global bc's neither garcia here's a bit
of that exchange
i did speak to tacoma schweppe mc chief
roseanne kasmir this weekend and she
calls your government pace of change
meaningfully when it comes to
reconciliation glacial and the amount
that you have prioritized reconciliation
so far in this campaign contrary to what
you just said
completely disappointing what do you say
to her and other indigenous people
across this country that feel the same
way i agree with the impatience that
people feel i agree with the impatience
that indigenous people feel because i
feel it too we need to be moving as fast
as possible but it's not just for the
federal government to decide we're going
to do this we're going to do that we
have to work with the communities
next one candidate's unique path to
politics
thousands of canadians are putting their
names on the ballot for monday's
election including dozens of first-time
candidates each with their own unique
reasons for their political ambitions
mike armstrong has the story of one
candidate's journey from secret service
to public servant
it's exciting there is something
completely different about running for
office and what huda mukbil used to do
for a living
campaigning means putting your name and
face all over that was something she
absolutely didn't do working as an
intelligence officer with canada's spy
agency i was in the security and
intelligence world uh in the shadows for
so many years
hi
i'm running for the next federal
election campaigning is about as public
as it gets mukbil's old job was about as
private as it gets
she spent 15 years at csis the canadian
security intelligence service i was not
in the public eye at all were you even
able to tell people you worked for csis
no my immediate family knew
but
my friends and
members of the community and
yeah
no one knew
my family fled civil war in ethiopia
mark bill's life is now a pretty open
book as a first-time candidate running
for the ndp the main issues that pushed
her into politics she says are systemic
racism and a lack of representation the
same issues that pushed her out of ces
it was hard you know what i went through
was really hard and buckville was part
of a lawsuit along with four other
employees against ceases they accused
the organization of harassment and
discrimination it was eventually settled
out of court and the csis director has
admitted the agency's culture needs to
evolve this year they're hiring the most
diverse class they ever have at thesis
so
so my work there is done
i have had the opportunity mukbil is now
hoping to take those issues to
parliament but to get there she'll need
an upset she's running against a liberal
incumbent who's won six elections in a
row it won't be easy and it's a big
change yeah she's literally gone from no
one knowing the job she had to everyone
knowing the job she wants
mike armstrong global news ottawa
and donna friesen will anchor our
extensive coverage on election night
monday right here on global television
as well as on history global news radio
and various online platforms including
globalnews.ca
and tomorrow donna will broadcast from
the last stop on our road trip ahead of
the election from brampton ontario
that's global national for this
wednesday i'm jeff semple thanks for
watching have a great night
[Music]
[Applause]
you